so comedy politics okay comedy politics
uh uh when I sit there and I watch
George Carlin I'm fascinated by the guy
how he would sit there and you know take
complicated and you just poke everybody
Troll make you feel uncomfortable laugh
and think all at the same time right if
you guys can do it some don't want to
touch it some don't want to get close to
it because like look I do anything but
politics I don't want to touch it
because of all this stuff what's the
risk of a comedian talking politics well
you could lose your audience I was told
not to talk about politics right so when
um after the Iraq War
um I started to turn more political in
my comedy which year the first one or
the second one second one okay gotcha
this is o4 not not yes yes 89 91. so and
then I got asked to do a a show at the
UCB theater opened up and uh in Los
Angeles and they asked me if I wanted to
do a show so I didn't know what to do
besides stand up right so I was I had
hurt my back and I was watching a lot of
news and I was just like well I'll just
use video clips and talk about how crazy
the news is and how bad it is because
the news is horrible right and so that's
when I started to become more political
and everybody told my manager my
everybody the club Owners like don't
talk politics Jimmy don't talk politics
you don't want to split your audience
right well I didn't listen to him and I
just kept doing it anyway and I got an
hour special out of it and night in 2008
it was called citizen Jimmy and it was
chosen best of the Year by iTunes and
punchline magazine so I approved all
those wrong good there you
go and uh and then when I then I got
hired by The Young Turks because they
saw my special and they were looking for
a fill and host and so then I I worked
there for about 10 years and that's all
politics you were with Young Turks for
10 years yeah about 10 years and what
you were there when Reuben was also
there yeah yeah that's how I met Dave
Rubin got it and yeah what did you do
with Young Turks was it with jenk and
those guys or was it your own show no I
was always on the main show a lot and uh
except after Trump got elected they
stopped having me on and um
because uh they all became you know
Trump deranged and uh I kept telling
them you can't have four Hillary voters
on a news panel and call yourself an
alternative new show you're not
alternative to anything your MSNBC and
so
um anyway so that I had my own show but
they put it behind a paywall and after
anyway so I left after they kept getting
Trump deranged and after the Mueller
report came out I thought everybody
would go back to normal because the
Mueller report said there's no collusion
and it was all revealed this was a big
psyop by the goddamn CIA and Democratic
party and all blah blah blah and uh they
didn't they didn't stop and they just
jumped on another horse and kept going
and I was just like I gotta get out of
here so I left and then uh it all went
to because their executive producer
when I did Force the vote I don't know
if you guys ever heard about that so
when the uh the squad got elected AOC
and those people they all got elected
and we're going to oppose the
establishment of the democratic party
we're going to oppose Nancy Pelosi we're
going to pull we're going to be the
progressives you know and and so I was
like okay so they won and then it was
such a small margin that the Democrats
held just like now with the Republicans
and so to vote for the speaker just like
they just did this time from McCarthy I
we wanted them to withhold their vote to
extract something and what we wanted in
the middle of a deadly pandemic as they
said uh well we want to vote on Medicare
for all because everybody on the
quote-unquote left had agreed for over a
generation that getting a vote on
Medicare for all and the house floor was
a big deal and we should achieve it even
in the DSA the Democratic socials of
America in their handbook in 2019 it
said the biggest thing we could do is
get a vote on Medicare for all and so I
came up with the idea hey it's like
eight votes or something it was very low
and I said so if you withhold your vote
for for Nancy Pelosi's speaker she can't
become speaker and what she should
demand is a vote for Medicare for all
because AOC had said that as she was
campaigning she said we can't even get a
vote for Medicare for all on the house
floor we can't figure to vote that's
horrible and then she said the
Democratic party is a conservative party
it's a center-right party those are
words that's verbatim from AOC so we're
like okay so now we're going to oppose
we're going to bring the Democratic
party back to the left we have leverage
just like the the Republicans just had
with McCartney Matt Gates and those guys
they had leverage they got a lot of
stuff
and they yeah I mean they brought
McCarthy to his knees he's 15 50 yeah
that's insane yeah right yeah and so
then and so what we wanted them to do
that they wouldn't do it and they kept
making up all these excuses why they
wouldn't do it now's not the time this
and then they got a lot of people in the
media like The Young Turks to
for them and uh guys like Ryan Grimm at
the intercept and they would they would
rant interference and tried the money of
the waters it's a very simple morality
play and they try to make it complicated
like it was hard to do and and so uh we
were Vindicated because Matt Getz and
the right wing just did the exact same
thing to McCarthy and people were lying
by the way so when I said they should do
they would go no if we do that Kevin
McCarthy will come become speaker which
is a lie that they can't happen and we
should Kevin McCarthy couldn't become
speaker when the Republicans have the
goddamn house so that was a big deal
that was forced to vote and um I've been
Vindicated I mean the people who have
supported it lots of people supported it
it wasn't just me it was guys like
Cornell West guys like Chris Hedges
Bernie Sanders former press secretary
Brianna Joy gray Medea Benjamin there's
a murian Williamson there's a lot of
people that were on board for this and I
would say about half the people who were
Bernie Sanders supporters maybe all of
them uh they didn't do it they got
exposed and now uh they're just go along
play alongs and there's no reason to
vote for Democrats at all today today
you believe that yes I tell people that
if you have any morality you will not
vote for one of these two pro-war
anti-worker parties you will vote for a
third party and people say well Jimmy if
you do you know third parties are not
viable at so what they're really saying
is you can't vote for a third party
until a lot of people are already voting
for a third party well how do you get
started you have to start voting for a
third party and that's why and so we got
to stop donating to them we have to take
you know there's only one party in
America with very very little
differences you know that right
your point is what with the people who
are behind it with the money that
they're giving so they have to kind of
please the same people and how well
years ago you know Obama and Clinton's
you know were bought by Wall Street and
then on the right is that kind of okay
yeah you got it so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]